let's go that's good everyone's mean to
everyone no they're not to me we just
started a podcast by saying everybody's
mean to everyone why accidents I'm
always nice to people I mean how can you
hold grudges for people that are mean to
you and you like already are successful
in comedy that's how I may be doing why
I hold grudges can elephant resentment
is that you do that I don't you're
complicated I don't you don't I know you
do hold grudges I know I do know he
doesn't isn't stay back now he's happier
you know you know when you're mad you're
mad no I get relocated
yeah hour goes by I'm good mad at me
once in the comedy store and I you
looked at me that made it made me it was
dark
no in you're mad you're mad he's mad
he's mad
can I just I was hurt because he thought
you'd sent you a text and you didn't
respond I'm getting big mobile first of
all you have to get off your name it's
good you use a calling card for your
phone it's not my problem you were doing
the church thing like Brendon I'll be in
the same room and he'll send me a tax it
just like will not go through I'm like
homie pay I think that was just a [ __ ]
block what's going on I get a better
carrier dude team almost pretty big time
they just took over Verizon to merge is
that right
Brandon has been bullshitting with fake
statistics since I got here I'm telling
you the only person to get a movie
greenlight Holly Shortell I know what's
up like where do you get the same feed
rod skillet no how do you know Verizon
just bought t-mobile
because uh t-mobile and Sprint spread
which is big yeah not Verizon Wall
Street Journal every morning I don't
feel like I even know you brand I read
as a reader he's reading a book a week
now I read a book it's not true try yeah
really what kind of book right now I'm
reading chaos Charles Manson CIA book
that sounds sinister yeah fascination
with serial killers I don't figure it
out I was just reading about how women
fall in love with serial killers well
women arm themselves with information so
I don't know a woman who hasn't been at
one point gone through a phase where
they were obsessed with sadistic this
year a man whose
dangerous yes so because that is a
turn-on like there's the science was
proven women are attracted to facial
scars well because apparently they're
all sorry there are two spectrums and
and this the far extreme where the man
is sort of the demonic ape-man is
aggressive and the alpha with the
biggest club and will kill everybody
there is something in apparently
evolutionarily that gene that extreme
gene Wilford odd provides you with alpha
children stronger children offer
protection while your innocence because
these serial killers they're cream no
that's a did a why am I in jail my my
but the bigger question for me is its
serial killers when they're in jail is
that man is that just a woman who wants
a guy who's in one place they're just
gonna be yeah yes games cheat Errol
Morris did a documentary on this I think
about some women are just attracted to
the boogeyman they want it's like it's
the same kind of impulsive somebody who
wants a lion isn't yet but here like
you've had it but just don't okay but
it's also it has to do with whether
you're on birth control or not if you're
on birth control your brain actually
thinks you're pregnant it releases
hormones as if you're pregnant so you're
attracted your favor you spell
pheromones differently so you're a child
that are more dangerous carry a knife
because your body you go we say we said
I got a scar look at my [ __ ] chain do
you buy he'll buy a Taekwondo kid I mean
he fell off first class but you know
Charles mance is like the most person I
tripped on the way out soon oh I'm sorry
about the sandals are over paid partners
brush my sandals oh no put that back to
Charles Manson you know he's the most
written about murder of all time yeah
and they're in this book they talk a
little bit about it it's like during
that time during the 60s and what it
represented in my
the drugs and there's like celebrities
tied to it it's just like this big drug
yeah yeah that's like like kept his
family like listening to him I think a
lot of women like those guys because
they feel like thanks bye for they can
understand for women didn't like him you
spy for Wow had marriage proposals when
he was in prison when he's in prison not
when he was like when he had the whole
family and stuff he was like everyone
was so drugged up and that's what the
defense of the the girls who committed
those murders even though they're like
20 21 they said they weren't in the
right frame of mind cuz they're so
drugged all the time what kind of just
like Wow and there's evidence of LSD
where you can like manipulate the mind
and you make him change the name no news
no no phones no they can't call anyone
so he'd create this environment around
them like this isn't a big deal we got
to kill these feet how do you explain
the women that show up to the Ted Bundy
trial that are in love with him that are
fans they want everyone else yeah they
want to change him they want baseline
I'm the one is that infantile crazy that
is have you seen this understood I can
get to him have you seen though this
like that does work by the way there is
a that sums up my entire dating a girl
who said she wanted to talk to some say
she was I could get to him I remember
this we were she was my girl we were
dating she goes I could get to him and
then did you continue dating this woman
well no I've [ __ ]
that's called a red flag I gifted her my
god can I said this is call him Saddam
let me ask you what are we gonna do what
are you dating someone
no you're single single is [ __ ] what's
the plan here well I just gonna be able
to slide back well it's been known I've
gone through the separation so I'm I'm
I'm most my time is spent with my
children him in Piven other times you
just kidding
I spend all my time with my as much time
as my children I'm not ready that's very
to me right now
you know I'm I'm managing that okay I'm
just curious if you're gonna do it or
the Rio routes if you're nowhere that
way no see my right now why not I don't
I'm just not ready for any of this I
don't mean like right this minute but
when you're ready no I don't did that
riah stuff it looks like it's Ryan
it looks like for the people listening
the don't know it's a dating app for the
rich famous it's like a eugenics program
any Instagram all you've ever seen is on
there it's tinder for people diggers and
dude that's what I means I'm not I don't
those women all look like mercenaries
literally I I was going to think I go
well they're all beautiful but they're
all looking for someone who's wealthy
and dad that's just you're wealthy I
feel like I was on the way over I feel
like you're rich now
yeah I have money yeah yeah that's good
but again okay fantastic there's all
that yeah Rio yeah you'll be surprised
that people know I've been Umrah I'm
aware yeah I'm fully aware I was on Raya
it's lots of models and photographers
that's the way that goes like did Miles
a photographer's had such a hard time
finding each other why did we need to
create that it's a lot of comedians a
lot of comedians they're on their email
comedians on that what should my picture
be hanging off a boat I come with him
you and tags I was on there John Cusack
is [ __ ] on there so talk you thank
his name is just Jay and then it's the
photo is the Damien Hirst Diamond skull
literally have you seen his Twitter no
well a piece where it's [ __ ] I
usually have huh what's famous he's
probably got money he's tall and
handsome well okay is it quite some time
he was in that movie wearing the trench
coat in the 90s that's in holding up the
boom box yeah and I say Ives I'm heading
for admit that now would be illegal
stalking but John Cusack look I was that
oh that's where he does his Raya from
but now look at his it's like political
tweets that are misspelled it's it's not
just all his but he is on Raya
I bet he's [ __ ] all those girls on
they're so young I don't know I said but
there's lots they have no idea it's
every guy that's a good point it's like
all the girls that you're trying to date
have never heard of you so you're just
kind of like for if we know who you are
you're hot if I've never heard of you
but there's lots of actors on there it's
like every guy that I've been avoiding
and how every Asian Solingen airs agents
on there pilgrims on there for a minute
yeah place to go man for that's some no
sad encounter I didn't do great on there
I mean I it was fine I had a lot of guys
like sending me like resumes really
there's a lot of that a lot of like hey
can I photograph you and then a lot of
guys pretending they don't know who you
are
oh that's a no which is just like a
bummer come on and then um a lot of uh a
lot of producers a lot of guys that I
know that are married they totally but
you can screen grab if you screen grab
you get kicked off so so they're married
they're married oh my god there were
like three or four people on that I know
you're gonna get caught though totally
but you can't [ __ ] screen grab oh no
that's fantastic what is this is this
who's on riah
yeah okay yeah Lots look we kept
scrolling and it shows me and Bruce that
yes
he's a youtuber oh yeah no that he's big
he's huge he's huge he on the fight with
a gun are arguing cuz like his the why I
know this I have no idea is that no like
Skrillex is on there lots of guys in
bands what are you like really the
Skrillex do you know script you know I
expect them to be on this Jonas is on
there a lot of like famous people he's
married he's gradually and old and by
the way I didn't know how to logout so
I'm thinking I'm still on it keep
scrolling check no need to [ __ ]
everything's I he's on there save some
for the rest of them I don't
why did I think quitting Riya so he was
on tinder Zak tinder now I just was on
there because I is that to me Lovato
yeah she's yeah she's on right talented
um
Briah I or no tinder I was on recently I
was doing a bit oh okay that's a moan
that is So Raven believed that got a
laugh I thought that was the corniest
haha
that's awful shame Mary she married no
she's not she's married or they know
she's engaged Orlando Bloom yeah she is
I'm very dry engaged Brendon I know a
lot of these things I'm wrong wrong sued
by women i I know yes by a woman and to
do is do a dude yes there was a guy who
accused her oh come on being awesome ah
yeah leave her alone not the Sprint
merger yeah I love Katy Perry yeah she's
being sued then well some woman she
tried to kiss a girl I guess big and
that's the cement some guy is some guy
what she was trying to hit I could get
out of here leave that [ __ ] she K is
there anybody don't use I mean worse
when guys complain about how to like
Terry Crews on it can I dump that boat
get off my get off my boat hold on hold
on I feel like the biggest complaint
I've been hearing for the past two years
from guys is how come this isn't
happening to women there's women they're
[ __ ] I've never said yeah
my friend if you like karate grab my
dick at a party but get over a dude get
over a guys are like well this also
should apply to women to help no no
my mouth so you guys are creeps that if
a woman at a party if you were wearing
loose joggers she could really she wants
your tight grab my dick wearing way too
bougie sweatpants that you should not
own and someone just a girl opens it to
show other people you're dead you don't
care no I wouldn't you wouldn't see a
blog the next morning would not your a
complaint you well you I would text
Brian like dude what this please respect
it doesn't matter no never complained
putting I would never get her in trouble
like oh this is different
double Stan I do believe that women have
a right I do believe that woman's
forever have not had any recourse so
it's not it this me to thing doesn't
really belong I mean maybe if you're a
gay man and you're working with another
gay man yeah that's a different things I
make you feel a cuff door merely guy
getting coffee
oh my coffee Andy Dick getting punched
that was [ __ ] up duty
do we know what he did before that don't
slap him in the deck well Andy Dick we
know licks people's faces so lucky
apparently yeah yeah Andy Andy after
this text I up and he gets drunk and he
gets drunk and he gets crazy so Andy
Dick can text you but I can't okay by
the way he got beat up pretty bad he was
down for 50 minute now cell being on
they thought he could he didn't get up
for 15 Rob the guy's you see this video
I'm assuming he grabbed something but
you know a tea party to Myrlie watch it
yeah it's rough man so that was nice
so if a guy pulls your dick out or you
in the dick that's not okay
no don't care I'll pause yet don't care
about any of it don't care don't if if
I'm gonna group and a guy don't know
like punch me in the dick well then I'm
praying in the beauty that's the other
thing it doesn't matter how many people
are around
no I again don't care about any of this
don't care about any of it if you grab
my things lady grabs my dignity check
out the hog on this one like your silly
anyways I'll take another Jameson yeah
okay if a guy tries oh Jesus Christ
knocks him out walks away grabs his beer
grabs his beer and walks the [ __ ] off
that was a heavy punch down for 15
minutes
yeah all that's out managed punch yet to
put easy but all we know it was that a
game it was at a gay bar and he grabbed
the guy's dick oh that's what I feel
like that's how they shake I didn't
think it was a gay
I was really [ __ ] with the wrong guy
it looks like I thought it was at his
while he was doing crap whoo Dan that
was a punch like you did with those
machines was it the back of the head I
don't know looks like we know how he is
now Z in the hospital
oh look at her now yeah there's a back
of the head and Eddie's a tiny I mean
you saw the you saw the Jim Jefferies
guy that came know what hit it chances
ages ago I mean I in general I was
talking a cry sure about this the other
day just the amount of danger we put
ourselves in when we go out and do mean
grease I mean you're fine I'm not why
because people know you cuz they know
they're not gonna beat me up so you have
to do other stuff so I bet like bomb
threats I love their stuff what what is
that but you never feel physically in
danger at your meeting grades mmm
conversation off the area oh okay but
I'll tell you this they better be yeah
you're well protected now and he wants
to [ __ ] around these nails and try
others there to keep kid did try to do
enzymes see what happens yeah Jim Jeff
what happens Jim Jeff Dean Jeffries I
mean this was ages ago this is kind of
like when he was before he just right
before he got famous a guy came onstage
just right Jim Jefferies punch on stage
a guy ran on see a [ __ ] punch I think
was in Australia I want to say what's it
it's okay Kevin Nealon hi Ken I love
Kevin that's Kevin show yeah yeah have
you done this it's the best it's really
fun though you gotta hide its Kevin does
this Kevin Nealon almost think I'm
hanging with that Kevin and you
basically watch him try to figure out
how to use a GoPro for like 40 minutes
like you and then you hide for five oh
man oh listen I got punched in
Manchester there's a lot of fighting in
Manchester
crazy goddamn Wow Jeff can't fight it
oh okay Jeff can't fight it all huh like
what the [ __ ]
apparently the story I heard about this
does it should the story I heard about
this is that he made some joke about or
was like doing some material suicide and
a guy in the audience had just lost
someone in his life to suicide or
something like he just stumped like
walked into the wrong hornet's nest
don't know that exactly I think that's
the only time that I would see complete
read if you saw the one who John Capel
rule oh the woman that threw a glass at
John Caporal oh I see red some guy did
that at the Comedy Store and I was
really big
yeah III was talking about being a Navy
SEAL joking around something like that
and he started he started like defending
the troops or something and I just saw
red like something happened to me where
I was like this guy's trying to be a
tough guy you know and I'm on stage yeah
and I you know me I have that temper
like I just what happens is I have Tufts
of such a long I had such a long fuse
but then once I see red yeah it's really
really I'm gonna fight I'm gonna go
crazy on you and I just was like I'm
gonna [ __ ] I think this is worth all
the jail so what was he doing was he he
suddenly lock up he shut the [ __ ] up
because I I was I was embarrassed by my
own reaction but something about him
pretending to be a guy standing up for
the troops and I was being insulting
made me [ __ ] see red maybe it was
that time of dad if somebody came on
stage and started punching it that's the
only thing that might you would see like
it's gonna be a disaster for them a [ __ ]
like Marc Marc Maron lose that's not
gonna be like that I oh hell no Marc
Maron I he went on like late and I went
up way earlier in the main room then
Marc went on like whatever for spots
after I was just I love Marc yeah stana
so I sit in the crowd and there's like
too gnarly do tackling them like from
Australia a dad and the son and like
probably did all the steroids from
koalas like they were jacked and they
kept harassing him and I see the comic
store like sound guys cuz Derick and
Assam mother who worked the front door
and they're like yeah I know
all right well yeah I get everyone cuz
gonna be a problem
I tell him that guys like [ __ ] off and
they keep harassing me mark just lights
him on fire like but he's just pissed
he's like what the [ __ ] you doing so
yeah yeah he's a proud that you know
like he goes well [ __ ] you don't tell
him proud like goo but then he get some
bad and he goes and it was fighting is
that god damn I walked my car after they
she's putting a beat me up and like
everyone's laughing but these guys keep
going and I'm looking at the comic store
security I'm like oh they're [ __ ] if
these guys want to hurt mark they're
[ __ ] so I hung around this be the only
time where yeah you gotta hang around oh
he's a guy threatened Chris like I
delete again yeah so I'm on I'm sitting
on the you know the wall the side of the
wall and there's this guy who's tackling
the comedian's kind of a strong looking
dude the one thing I can't take is a
bully yeah I'm gonna fight I I can't I
can't so I'm sitting on the wall and he
and I go if he does it I'm like hard you
know you've been with me where my heart
light no no no I'm gonna no he was
heckling Chris and then Chris was
walking and I saw him mark Chris and I
go if he does anything to Chris I'm
gonna fight I said that to something I
think it was somebody was next to me and
I my heart starts beating I go vomit
we're gonna go now I'm gonna go I'm
gonna fight this got a knock I'm gonna
punch him right now do you like does
your brain in that moment go okay this /
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna I don't know
I don't know I just know her I just know
that it's worth all the jail time and
the risk I'm going I'm going because I
saw him he gets in Chris's face of his
book like that and you can ask Chris
what I did after what Chris do huh
did chris go chris acts completely
inconvenienced he doesn't get mad the
way I do yeah Chris is like ah dude
whatever
come on oh you see really thank God the
guy the guys and he's a tough-looking
guy yeah but um that's it so now he
tries to come pass me and I get now I
get in it's that small space and I'm I'm
moving my shoulders I'm going right on
the side asking him to do one thing to
move on me because I want to show him
what I'm gonna do because I turn my body
I'm going imagine if I'd let my fist go
on I'm doing this right in front of him
Chris is like and then I thought the
bathroom was his friend and I look at
the bouncer who's this big and I'm so
angry I go and dude if you're gonna try
to protect him I'll cut through you like
a [ __ ] knife through a hot butter so
I'm gonna beat you up afterwards is that
your friend I was so angry I'm doing
this he goes like this he he he looks at
me he goes you UFC the UFC I go no I'm
gonna [ __ ] you I'm losing my mind
and he goes he goes he goes this is my
spot this is my spot and you're doing
that to my friend so now we're in a
world of trouble because you're not
going anywhere it's no way I so crazy
not imagine a situation where a comedian
who defended themselves against an
audience member would ever get in
trouble look I don't know what happened
to me but Chris is like staring and the
guys I was this this is you have signed
up for an arrangement where you go
listen to someone else talk discourage
anybody say nothing but that's how I
will with with Marcus thing you know if
these guys got in stage let's say I
knocked them out is Adam that kicked me
out of the car oh you wanna know were
you there the night that someone brushed
the stage
odds to burn in the oro it was wild and
it happened so [ __ ] fast and you know
cuz the o are at the Comedy Store is so
dark they I mean I trip every time I
want that's me I'm like negs everyone
like stop your [ __ ] tour yourself in
this [ __ ] so I remember someone came and
Steve Byrne doesn't play around no like
I don't like I didn't also the best guy
in the world I didn't know that about
Verne because he's the nicest [ __ ]
guy the first person that was ever nice
to me in comedy it's actually a really
embarrassing story
because when I first started comedy I
was on my it was my space days and I had
gotten a spot on Last Call with Carson
Daly don't be jealous
my space top-8 friends don't be jealous
oh my god 30 to 40 views I want to say
see burn reached out to me was like yo
if you're over New York let me get you
some spots like okay I'll hook you up
the seller and enough and I'm like all
that's a night like out of nowhere to
this day no one's ever done something
like that I've never done that such I
would never do that it's just so
incredibly time-consuming to be as nice
as it so he called the comic strip he
called the Comedy Cellar he called when
there was an improv in New York
Caroline's he got me eight spot does it
in a weekend that's Steve burn media on
Last Call with Carson Daly so I get to
New York and he's like well let me know
for it the same club let's like meet up
great I fully think I'm gonna have to
[ __ ] him fully prepare I'm fully
prepared I'm like God my deodorant on
I'm all set and we meet up and I'm like
fully like okay I guess I have to date
this person like whatever this exchange
I didn't for dating this how we're
together he shows up with a model I was
like oh my god he's just this nice and
well he's that nice yeah I'm real model
and I was like oh no Steve he's always
nice if you [ __ ] with Steve it's not a
game yeah so someone rushed though arm
yeah cuz I've seen him because I used to
open for him on the road a little bit
and I saw like a couple times when
people disrespected him it did not go
great and then he like he doesn't he
doesn't tolerate disrespect you know
this guy came out from on stage and Bret
Ernst was there too I just remember
seeing Bratz like run through the
audience over the chairs like and it was
just like okay I think from me I feel so
I'm not a tough guy as you know I'm not
there's nothing compared to the guys
like this I'm nothing but I think that I
feel tougher than a lot of comedians
because they're I always look at them as
dysfunctional misfits and if somebody's
gonna come at them so a good example as
my buddy is it works with he's a lawyer
for children and foster care and his
whole life has been to protect people he
would he'd be the one who had who had
adopt a three-legged mutt all he does is
a caregiver he's just always been the
voice for the for the Forsaken and the
for gone this guy this giant dude he
would he went down says hey can you guys
keep it down because my girlfriend's
trying to sleep in this giant guy goes
what are you gonna wear but I what I'm
saying is that he felt like a coward
because the guy punked him he was he was
Brian I was terrified yeah you're
supposed to be you've never thrown a
punch
I don't think about this and this giant
guy is putting you in water that you
don't even have to swim in yeah I did
that's not what your thing is has make
you a coward it means you're a gentle
human being in this guy like Brendan
with the cauliflower ears everybody's
gonna be terrible so I feel always that
when comedians like someone like Chris
who's an innocent I was not thinking
about this and this guy's in his face so
never do you think Chris can fight no I
never pictured no he said he goes the
only time I guess I said cuz I remember
we were in me and Dov and Chris he had a
tank top on he was walking around at
Eknath husband he was a featuring for
Dov and I yeah and this this rough
looking guy just sees Chris his hairy
chest and he's walking all Angry he
doesn't give a [ __ ] his body's all like
soft and he looked like here that it was
a pattern he looks so ridiculous and
we're walking through this group and
this rough San Diego thug look in the
fight just looks at Chris goes I mean
goes like [ __ ] [ __ ] like that and
Chris just goes I caught the whole thing
I go did you see that guy he's like
trying to fight you in any circumstance
you'd fight he goes I mean no nothing
and I go I mean he goes I guess if
somebody hit my mom I would like tweet
Nev [ __ ] Urban's not in his DNA he acted
when the guy goes in his face yeah
who likes starting [ __ ] more but won't
you know to mean because he does why did
you two start that's gonna physically
yeah now he's in Albuquerque and it's
show danger he's supposedly designed a
copy shop even dinner by himself that's
just Christmas but he doesn't like he
thinks everyone is in on the joke
yeah but also people will never know who
the [ __ ] you're gonna piss off and I
think that they're gonna do when I in
other words
chris has never had a relationship with
violence you know he's afraid of
violence and fighting on Street that guy
cuz he father you know what people who
knows they're exactly what's gonna
happen
yeah and he knows other confessions over
yeah it's terrifying and one unless you
find the cushon the less you find what
you don't say struggle city but he's got
because I great way to make fun of his
coming out next month I gotta go well I
think there's this new level of crazy
that I'm noticing that's like it's one
person that can weird out the whole room
just because they're not conforming to
the agreement we all have so talking
about audience member yeah I've been
noticing it shows recently and I don't
know if it's cuz a podcast where people
feel so close to you now or they feel
like you owe them in some way because
they supported you so much because
they've listened to you for a hundred
hours you know so they feel like and
you've been in their living room you've
been in their car you know and uh I had
this guy recently who just every time I
would do a joke and there'll be like a
little laugh break he would raise his
hand and just ask a question and it was
like not TED talk dude it was a hundred
percent I had to do do we're not on a
five but it just kept being like hey so
how's your mom doing and it was like it
was there was no he wants to wear your
face there there was no physical danger
but something and you're just got is
like this guy isn't abiding by the rule
you know like he's did it [ __ ] up the
vibe it [ __ ] up and everyone's nervous
no one it's just it's not scary it's
just like there's something going on
with this person's neurology you say
that like you're The Improv or someone
was that bigger no it's that's theatre
and he had like great seats and had all
the stuff and had that you know it's
like someone that you feel bad about
kicking him out cause he's not on yes
it's not what you have to it makes you
the [ __ ] because what do I say
besides like he just like ask questions
at the wrong time like it's a mean greet
you can totally do this because the fact
that you don't know how this Agreement
works me it's like seeing during a
[ __ ] opera what are you doing dude
yeah it's just like this isn't how this
goes you know so that to me is sometimes
the scariest [ __ ] where'd you shoot your
special DC oh you did yeah
what and it's called you you can I tell
you which is crazy do any research
alright like yeah have you follow me on
it sir thank you I think you're
fantastic I and I think it's a the trust
to do right
that's what DC is the train 90 still the
chocolates it not anymore used white man
in college there in there it's not
anymore I call the chocolate city
no don't subject that's that's connected
Lana that's Atlanta Atlanta is it
chocolate city DC is not the chocolates
no well they they used to be so you can
tell the suburbs me she call it that DC
was very broad west is behind that it
was very black maybe it is the chalk
I'm sorry I called the chocolate city
first of all always consider who is the
bad boys I was just with them yeah I
shot in DC why do i DC because I think I
was a little bit of a place where I was
like I was finding there was such a
disparity between what like people
wanted to hear in middle of America
versus New York LA San Francisco it was
just how bifurcated our country has been
and I was talking about like you know
sexual harassment I talked all about you
know what's been going on in the news
and I went to Houston I had the [ __ ]
most gnarly experience where I was
talking about like getting my ass
grabbed at work or something and trying
to figure out that joke and this older
woman in the Houston I can't so he was
at the improv
whatever that big beautiful improv that
and I was like yeah so when a guy grabs
your ass at work
to yelled out take the compliment and
move on that's what I'm saying that's it
sure that's a joke I was such a totally
it is like [ __ ] like we are in such an
echo chamber in LA and this is so
tone-deaf in terms of like what the
average woman experiences the average
man - I have a lot of friends who are
waitresses that I went to school with
that are like I flirt for tips yeah sex
is the only power I have we're in a
weird bubble and it [ __ ] blew my mind
that I was like I'm only hearing one
point of view and that's not healthy and
that doesn't make for good comedy and I
really want this to be a fair special
and I noticed like you guys know like
the the what I think is an epidemic and
comedy of like laughter where you say a
premise that people think is like brave
or progressive and they just start
clapping and then you can't get to the
punch talk too much
oh yes you know and so it's just that's
not comedy and I found myself anytime I
would talk about sexual harassment not
trying to be like progressive or any of
that just in people look like that and I
was like looking woman oh but I don't
want that I don't yeah sorry for me this
is not no um like me trying to get some
glory out of this moment I just it you
know so I went to a bunch of cities and
then I tried to go to a city that was
like kind of neutral that was not gonna
feel too left or too right and really
smart people that we're gonna kind of
get it did that sex doll but first of
all it's a robot like to borrow a big
way honestly great transitional but but
I mean that's a real thing it's a real
thing I think my house and I was gonna
buy what I was gonna buy Brian one for
Christmas why don't you just buy Whitney
don't what the hell is that it weighs
150 grand okay that was $50,000 what's
the friend discount here $50,000 doll 20
bucks final offer offer yeah there's
just how did you
she talked in six months she can have
eyeballs that are cameras god here's the
thing though who made you posting videos
of him making this robot looks
exhausting it's exhausting have you seen
this it was a full time she post six my
deaf they don't follow it but she posted
anything about no fir pudding like all
this [ __ ] on to make the robot that's
terrible yeah I'm claustrophobic
alright it's laughter a gaming
tell you there was something sort of
soothing about it where oh yeah this is
like making the ear and molding the face
it took six months to make I actually
had to push the special taping because
she wasn't done yet that's incredibly
want to play it or do this format to
know that your current face no no thank
you for the face I put on every morning
I have my lids none and just wait you're
gonna be so I tell you I feel like guys
are getting plastic surgeries like that
well I feel like you look up oh hold
right hell yeah
my mother keeps trying get your lids
down so all brides on a bad idea will
suck up a lot of people have the lids
none and apparently the scar is in the
eyebrow you can't see so you can't see
it you don't understand you know I look
into I'm not gonna do it the bags under
my eyes you know they can just shoot
some stuff in there and gets rid of this
no that's not true I don't think that I
went through this cuz I get really bad
under-eye bag - yeah really bad it's
just what you do I went there's that but
I went to this guy - guys this guy dr.
Lancer who's like a really famous and he
was like we can put filler we can put
filler in but the problem is he called
it a column a filler we can put a column
a filler in but that's when you start
looking puffy getting that like a puff
you already are puffy your skin so you
could fit well I don't even see what
you're talking about
I got rest last night but usually I've
bags and he said that I put those
patches on and I put him in the freezer
and I and then I put two coke cans on my
face every morning so much won't go down
I'm out too much he said you're not
allowed to eat salt
I'd say [ __ ] off yeah so I said I had
yeah so I started on this like no salt
if I'm shooting something like right now
I don't give a [ __ ] about this so I
don't do it but nobody drove from
Woodland Hills drove from what they said
we live yeah and we're neighbors we're
neighbors now we're neighbor yeah
everybody's out there yeah pas moi
master house with a giant pink Hummer
and I was like oh there's
your house looks like a rap video
columns designed by Versace it has a big
like t on the gate yeah live kid like we
have to bring back MTV Cribs I feel like
you I agree be very good at that
no they said that it would create a
column and you would just look puffy and
swollen so I didn't do it but I would be
careful I feel mom not do some people
feel like audacity to now I can do this
stuff yeah but there's I will just
tighten it up being but that's harder no
that's not yo yo we know some people in
common that have done that share in
their ears just like start mining so you
have to know they say that because I was
talking to this guy I was like why does
all plastic surgery look so bad it was
like it doesn't good surgery you don't
notice that's right yeah so there's tons
of actresses it's Tom Cruise and Brad
Pitt what do you think they're do I
don't think they're doing really yeah
I'm B so I wish I bring a brand new
shoes like people do like you Tom Cruise
whispers of like and they put they do it
in places do you would imagine so when I
got my ear bitten off number I went to
this guy from this we even talked to
this no I'm the only person that has a
Lear ear than you no I don't think so
yeah look I still got chopped I have the
same thing right my head you don't have
the same thing you had your ear we have
the same thing oh we don't mind bitten
off my whiskers was doubled mine was cut
off then did you get a cut off my mom
accidentally cut what she's got my hair
when I lift up my ear off oh wait I
thought that was from wrassling no wait
the whole thing no just the top she cut
the top off anyways your ear everything
I hear about her I just a plus a plus B
plus C plus one bit up a dog bit my ear
off and then we had to sew back on we
had to get it sewn back on kill him why
are we talking about this now plastic
surgery no Oblast surgery oh so the guy
that was doing it is the head of the
facial transplant team at UCLA and
Cedars or Rev I've got it done and he
was like oh should we put filler in here
to fix it I was like I don't really give
a [ __ ] but he was explaining that the
good
work is not the place you think it would
be so when women get like facelifts
they'll put filler here in the temples
and it just shows everything up yeah
just pulls everything up and then the
first sign of aging is the cartilage on
your nose gets buried disconnecting
Hatchett so it stops looking so hook so
you'll have a dick note I got I got a
nose by the way wasn't your dick look
like I mean it's got you it's still
straight with a heavy vein you know
exactly what I think back here you go
this is for you yeah laughs at my memory
of my day
don't laugh at the memory of my dong
well your nose I can say from experience
your nose like nothing like Brendan's
day when I swear he's in both our dongs
and Tom Cruise's face the whole time
he's had work done broke cartilage on
your nose so you dig that's why everyone
goes to Brazil they go to get that
surgery why Brazil those cheaper and
just a good question I don't know I
don't work out so well for ushers mom I
would honey wait wait so now I got to
get my god that is actual if I get my if
I get my nose that reattached if I get
you this time you would see the bigger
problem with your nose is more than yeah
it's very different nose ring there when
I was younger and what am i okay I don't
know these stuff does you know what else
you can do what's wrong you get filler
that's not what your nose looks that way
be look at my nose right oh it's worse
they're not a bad I'm not a bad
handsome yeah you know well I saw
rapport yesterday Michael yeah a meeting
at Soho House and I hear what the [ __ ]
that's in the middle why are you going
to somehow house the better questions
that's where you get all your industry
might knows there's we find out about
Maya I was on Rodrigo from Riya their
main Tina
um Brian where knows I haven't there a
long time like Andrew Santino how Zeo do
young what's this I don't probably the
store but look at my little cute nose in
my little I tell you Brian I feel like I
can say this but I've you're very
handsome
thank you yeah you are I feel like in on
some other universe we would have dated
I know you would have like destroyed my
20s I would have did some other you know
and I would have been really nice to you
yeah you can destroy my 40s anyway yeah
it's gonna be an old man and I'll get my
lads time I show up looking everything
how old is that picture of me and count
on the [ __ ] hold on you can never do
those awards now the guys only awards on
Spike really that was so much fun yeah
hey is this how the show works now you
just look up yourselves know you guys
run it up that's from that's just 116
yeah like three years ago yeah yeah no
just walking the red carpet together
yeah times were different man exactly
three years ago Wow Wow I know a lot of
people getting necklace necklace hmm you
just pulled the neck it's just the neck
there's also do you know about the
string look that up I want that this is
what a lot of people this is what a lot
of people apparently do it's a string
that goes in from behind your ear under
your chin and then it pulls everything
back you don't apparently it's like a
you do it at lunch and you can go home
Brian get that bro I'm quite as
dissolves I think I'm a certain amount
of time what's it called the magic
string or something otoplasty writing to
Grandby I'll get I'll pay for it that's
great I'll pay for it
apparently threading is a big thing
here's a plan though why can't you just
get it done once and it's sticks you
always got like keep doing it like girls
who get their lips done they can't see
how to do it
thing that doesn't dissolve what do you
want them to put in their [ __ ]
concrete metal yeah and how do you know
they keep getting it done what is this
where are these statistics coming from
oh I'm sorry fact check boxes at last
sorry random statistic McGee get your
lips done once and then you're good for
life
it's Botox Botox has a show I don't
think it's Botox Botox in the living
that freezes lips isn't filler and
filler does not last for life you ask
any girl you've ever dated besides me
correct that's how I know I know so they
tell you yes why why wouldn't they know
I like to know what's going on um I
can't wait to get plastic surgery this
give me I'd say get your nut I think
that it's I my neck doesn't need doing
yet come on but you would just pull it I
think wrinkles hurt here's the problem
with guys wrinkles are sexy Yeah right
clothes are good yeah but you look good
you look as good as I've seen you thank
you yeah you look healthy Jesus our ears
are a little high I sleep a lot there's
nothing you can do about that about
yourself I do think though that lift lip
injection ever since the lip injections
everyone thinks my lips are fake because
I think everyone's are fake now so you
don't look like your fake lips yeah well
I can we've had them for but you've had
them for a hot second yeah I mean all
your lips in Greenup sands yeah thank
you but everyone thinks my cheeks are
fake too because now people put
Restylane is that what it's about why am
I looking at a perfect face right I know
there's something you can put in your
cheeks now to make them higher yes so
everyone thinks that I do that well I
forgot it's tricky for guys she'd do it
and it's implants big surgery it's again
like this size calves calves are
grotesquely big yeah is because while
calves and I think it's uh
PEC implants are number one for guys
pecky I didn't plant but I think is
getting
technology starting to get there dude um
got recalled I think so I don't know
what hey you did somebody somebody tried
to extort you and then you know it
anyway but why did girls like you have
nice breasts waited way to just get past
that you really like to go up to the
hard-hitting double well let's try to
store you anyway yeah but the way you
hold your alright yeah no these are
amazing so I don't run again I don't
know I'm just not dealing with it you
know yeah I just power through it yeah I
just like white-knuckle through it wanna
just bite down we get out these are my
tips yeah someone tried cuz you posted a
story right and they clipped I thought
it was gonna be like some real
scandalous picture oh my god oh [ __ ]
there we go
and then you post the pictures all
that's it looks like a home birth oops
oh [ __ ] no it was not a flat okay no I
was it was a weed is now legal in
California which has had some
devastating side effects for me because
I randomly will just like get in the
bathtub and start doing like a stupid
story and I didn't want and my boob was
showing at a very unflattering [ __ ]
angle and then I posted it and then
somebody told me to take it like you did
it you're doing you know I took it down
and then a couple months later these
people started saying like you have to
pay me 50 grand or else I'm gonna sell
it to the happening or like so I know
like a favor
I know well I wasn't I saw some good
news in my phone like this was the most
unflattering photo like it was such a
bummer cuz it's like there's so me this
has happened and women have been
extorted but it's over a photo they like
posed for and like stand behind ya I
just looked like yeah if you're gonna do
it here here use this yeah mine looks
like this hold it mine looks so like
medical if you're gonna see my dick it
can't be on a cold day right you know if
you had extort me people just do it with
this pic that's all I ask
they sink in a bad angle I'm like
holding a loofah like no water but i was
trending on pornhub everyone told me
that was a big big deal I know that's
what everyone I mean I had people
reaching out to me that were like
congratulations you're turning on porn
you made it yeah which is my eye which
is about how I found out what time all
my guy friends jerk off hit like 8:30
a.m.
anything on porn are you I'm gonna get
Jordan Rubin texted me like 9:00 a.m.
but yo this is awesome [ __ ] yeah it was
a pretty big deal I was right about
dominance do you watch porn
honestly I don't watch it really yeah
definitely do Brian you do I can add in
what so I mean it's it's not as a
grownup ends on how much you're watching
it cuz isn't on the cruise like it's
more they aren't is an erectile
dysfunction I think 33 percent of men
that watch too much porn are getting
right oh I just I just can't remember
less my fingers you're like no problem I
thing is flying it doesn't do a [ __ ]
thing for me maybe because I've watched
it before it doesn't do anything for me
you walk about them because I'm not a
pervert but I just porn doesn't mean I
watch the right guy strip clubs in porn
your life he's your favorite
it used to be belladonna back in the day
she's the greatest I thought were you
watching you know who God is the bad
she's the sexiest I see Akira oh yeah we
I got my sex robot majestic I my nipples
they said you have aa secure inifels
belladonna terrible belladonna and what
is the best porn star mean the most
polite oh the sex oh wow his face is
tough no her face is beautiful her she
was the sexiest thing to me I'm looking
her up belladonna well we got a computer
here lady she I don't know I mean she's
a little older that's her was Uniting
Cox around her she was so just she was
so indecision she's doing a Mic Check
when she started out forget it well what
did that mean belladonna okay so let me
ask you something if you are watching a
porn star like do you go back to the
same porn star so the reason I liked her
is I actually believed she loved sex
back in the day like she was the best
actor with porn I always feel like I'm
watching damn a climb yeah I'm watching
damn it yeah with her back in the day
and I know a guy used to work with her
she was just a sexual animal not when
she was younger mm-hm and I believed it
right see ride outside careless do like
she's like I'm fine like I my parents
love the [ __ ] out of me yeah she's
so our intelligence she's really sushi
zombie I think yeah yeah um we have the
same nipples so I mean man I think
you're overthinking the porno though huh
just giant I am I am I am I am it
doesn't turn me on but so if you if you
okay you're going to whatever donate
sperm I don't know and you're gonna go
jerk off what do you put in I would put
it in you come I was put in nacho nacho
and belladonna or rock or rocco siffredi
you care about the guy you're watching I
do I do
nachos got a piece on him and I liked
when he was young right these are when
they were younger guys I know you're
such a pervert I don't know any male
porn there is their main issue I don't
know what to do
porno use these to you stuff Wow very
younger
okay so right have you not watch porn in
the year 2000 no I mean I don't maybe I
don't know see there this is how I used
to have good was that long ago it was
for me thought out no you're watching
porn nobody I just don't I really don't
learn if you had to watch it what kind
would it be like to mix it hmm are you
the popular page just a tenth papi but
porn how are you porn you porn but then
sometimes I bring up like you might like
and it's like a trainee I'm like what
gave you that it's a transsexual oh [ __ ]
off that's what you actually that was
general assignment surgery what is it we
all in this show Tran Tran it just what
what I don't know Chan I call it Tran a
[ __ ] trans transexual
oh [ __ ] what did I say [ __ ] what's
wrong with that whatever nothing you
know here's a great joke oh this is
Michael chica he goes eh eh yeah [ __ ]
you Jake he goes I'm bad with these hey
he goes uh because I didn't realize that
it was offensive to call transsexual
[ __ ] yeah and then
I met a transsexual and I said man I
don't get it what's wrong with [ __ ]
and she goes you all right can I call
you Blackie you a fair point he's so
funny
you silly Instagram stories are real
human really you will tear into people
to do him ignorant [ __ ] and just put
them on the husband is so funny yeah he
can't know I don't know he kills me but
yeah you put [ __ ] into you poor that's
how they do it not that I don't know yes
because is that okay so what I don't
watch be trans I just want to make that
very clear I don't want you why not
doesn't turn them on it's just not my
thing
okay got it I'm not sure me on yeah I do
by the way there's not accusing you of
this will you say at all okay there are
a lot of MMA fighters who are into that
I don't think so
well where do you get your research
research the new fact McGee I have some
friends who are trans and some very
famous MMA fighters have reached out to
how I'm sure mm-hmm I'm sure that I
would loved it talk off here about how
about the girl you tell me about who was
very heavy very heavy and she said just
watch how many guys hit me up oh yeah
after secretly oh yeah she's super heavy
she goes oh he's omniscient get all the
do that's right atomic number chunky
yeah big girl she and I was like you do
you like because she's my mother dating
life on Mikey struggle she's like she's
all excuse me yeah and make sure
murdered and was like yeah yeah it's
really thick this is not a [ __ ] joke
when I went down and I did the made the
sex robot him myself going down to the
factory that builds the sex dolls
because she's a sex doll body in a robot
head the dolls the number one request
from the guys buying sex dolls is they
wanted them to be heavier the technology
just isn't available yet here's a
problem thicker or have fear like thick
like a curvy most guys like athletic
curvy yeah
up fat yeah big strong legs big ass
small waist there's nothing wrong with
that it's fan time I feel like within
now is small boobs big butt go to amis
go to Graham amazing lifters I feel like
like bodies why are we going to lifters
why show you are lifting gay no these
growths that are old like like the first
one there are Invictus or this girl who
lifts weights look at her body for a
second let go good or go to her
Instagram if she wasn't lifting weights
and you just saw her in a bikini on the
street yeah no problem you can't keep
going down keep going she's pretty she's
adorable
yeah and she's thick though she's a big
strong girl but I find no she's on
steroids Oh correct that would be anavar
probably buddy yeah and when all the
animal you find that sexy or not I
[ __ ] loves that I love strong you
like hard yeah I like big strong girls
like that he likes girls that are so
close to growing a dick but look at her
body like there look at her back and
look at her butt there
I got no problem yeah I I mean I I'm a
fan would look like that you have a
great body I try joking could now I
train with Ben I'm good we'll get you in
the way on that quick we'll get you
we'll get to move around
okay see she's attractive be but there's
a lot that yet some of them I mean yeah
obviously and you lie dance but they're
all they're all yeah but you know at the
end of the day I step it up and I
surprise them and they're like what the
[ __ ] yeah you're all hold on well who is
this person she's pretty for sure this
one of the girls when I hunter um
prosper I knew exactly Team USA she's
she's a competitive weightlifter like a
competitive on guys can just like [ __ ]
in ice baths every night she's a real
athlete okay you know real athlete do
you think that that would be weird no
really no you don't think you guys would
get competitive
no I'm not like I'm not a computer on
the same field yeah hmm I just find out
like what if she was like taking a pro
oh Jesus she's a real athlete what if
she was like taking a protein powder you
didn't think this I have to we'd have to
get into it I'd be like fight over
anything those ABS are sexy yeah I do
you don't like that oh you're gay man
all I needs a bigger car that's right I
think it's cool that you're into that
but look at her she's I think it's cool
you're open about I think she's adorable
no she's pretty like Oh something super
sexy about like this is me
as a I guess I'm not I'm trying to be a
straight man
is there something sexy about the her
ambition - oh yeah like when I yeah are
now usually just actually look at I'm
known as she's not someone who has
driving has their own thing is supersize
like that's what I see that's the first
thing I see got her it's like discipline
we took loyalty I like her character
based on the body competitive athlete
where you look at my body and you see
someone who just like different no
commitment no I think you look like
you're in ridiculous a that I think
you're working out all the time in your
line I never work no I I gotta pee out
of my weight what is the brake like so
you're gonna go and cut all the crazy
[ __ ] up no wow support for the fighter
kid comes from manscape who's number one
in men's below the belt grooming get it
manscaped offers precision-engineered
tools for your family jewels yes snip
snip snip you know what a big secret is
for men like us
you got a man scape do dude I got a trim
this sack yes Adam times I Nick it and
one thing about my balls dude they be
bleeding dude snagging your sack
snagging your sack is one smack don't
snag your sack they got manscape has got
a proprietary skin safe technology it's
a trimmer where you can you can bring
your nutsack down to a you can make it
as smooth as a baby's yeah I'm an
engineer engineer geez injuries are a
thing of the past is what you're trying
to say nah dude I'm talking about
manscape has tools for your family jewel
crop preservers an anti chafing ball
deodorant Cowboys riser put dealer under
your arms when I put on your sack I'm
not man what are we doing that's 20% off
right now free shipping with the code
fighter at manscape calm always use the
right tools for the right job
your nuts will thank you get 20% off and
free shipping with the code fighter at
manscape comm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape calm
trim it fighter safely hey bee there's a
lot of tools out there that track your
heart rate they might do a thing here or
there maybe you're on a bike like I am
I'm like damn I'll burn in a thousand
calories but I'm not yeah or how about
you think you're getting good rest you
think you're doing the things right you
think a good diet
but you're not really tracking it right
you're not tracking with the best device
possible you mean you talk about whoop
what about wait for in this tool change
the way people track their fitness and
optimize their training it really is
kind of amazing I mean before I even
knew about it you were wearing it and I
said you you were you're comparing it to
other I've had a bunch of watches yeah
and you said this was the best by far
the best you were a customer before you
this this became some wrecked whoop is a
performance tool you get a whoop strap
which is a heartrate monitor that
measures your heart rate a hundred times
per second twenty-four hours twenty-four
seven you can charge it while you're
waiting you don't even take it off just
put on the little battery it charges it
usually lasts about five days mine last
a little longer so five days without a
charge yeah so what's what measured like
what am I gonna do though your recovery
look at your heart rate it make sure
you're getting the right rest if you're
not zero your strain how well you're
working out it checks your resting heart
rate max heart rate calories burned the
amount of exertion you're putting out
throughout the day your sleep - all that
REM deep light it does all that man it
provides all these insights down to the
nitty gritty and you got to get the new
whoomp 3.0 strapped that's what you need
to do go to whoop go to whoop comm whoop
there it is WH Oh Oh Pete calm use the
code fighter at checkout save thirty
dollars to optimize the way you train
again that's woop comm promo code
fighter for $30 off the way you got to
do it right to track your training get
to shred Sadie trades times up on hunch
stop calling women hon elderly man
was that your Pedialyte delivery are you
ordering some mr. good bars is that to
get your oh Henry shipment yeah sweetie
okay sweetie by doing no just call hon
are we recording a show I don't know
what's happening right now B what's
happening I've been here since 12:15
that's what we do here for four hours we
have 20 minutes of usable 20 minutes of
material does comedy seem easy to people
it does it does it doesn't because we
make it look easy probably I feel like
comedy stand-up has a bad like a PR
issue it's the hardest job it's okay
though because people find out very
quickly but actors like me I guess I'll
do that but then they find out very
quickly that they can't yeah Charlie
Sheen yeah that is that it gets quiet so
quickly after two minutes it means lasts
for 30 seconds that's right Tommy store
lasts for literally 30 sighs talking
about this with dick post in Portland
we're talking about famous people trying
comedy yeah I went at the Comedy Store
you get 30 seconds yeah yeah the
greatest place on earth
yeah and they have such a high standard
yeah yeah some other places you might
get a minute two minutes right god
that's that guy from that where if you
make fun of yourself and yeah movies
you've done you know you do like a
reference to a movie down after the
two-minute laughter max now what are you
doing for the other 58 minutes what's
your game plan right no actually I think
it hurts you sometimes when you're
famous cuz the bar is even higher he
will probably spend more money on
tickets expecting some product yeah I
used to seeing on I would imagine the
non famous comic who's headlining in
your city is funnier than the celebrity
that you've heard of guaranteed
guaranteed it depend what City why
where's that boy alive okay research
McGee my fight with me about that i'ma
go
Bagheera because I generalisation Mageau
yes here we go random statistics okay
well Orlando some so does that not apply
have you have you seen the comedy scene
or land or and smoke down Washington
I've only been doing this for 20 years
so you know this different markets lot
of different markets where they're not
as good thank you so much very slightly
that's the point I know but I don't
think mmm I'm just saying any comic
you've never heard of that's coming to
Orlando is gonna be funnier than Jeremy
Piven I'm sorry does he listen to this I
haven't seen this to mr. comedy I've
seen him do no I've seen it
stand up stop scene it's common ain't we
tried on all this I don't know where
we're going with this we're making sorry
you can't cut that out I know honey if
you didn't feel man whatever maybe the
same point yeah we are well this is the
nature of our relationship we agree but
we're arguing about and I have t-mobile
the same point to each other but we want
to be the person to win yeah it's very
strange I'm surprised we haven't seen
more more of a Australian English
invasion into our comedy scene we've
seen it in acting yeah how did his
comedy though yeah I think different I
do know somebody I love or no
weightlifters for Michael G yeah I did
notice though a guy friend of mine who
is a comic in England came over here
went to the comedy store mom
janessa take off in no in the UK because
in the UK you can call anyone come to
any time it's yes the colobus what they
do yes yeah which I do [ __ ] over there
is offensive but over here you can say
oh that guy's a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
that girl's a [ __ ] my wife's a [ __ ] I
don't know and then [ __ ] makes everyone
uncomfortable so he got on stage like
what's up cons I might like I saw it
happen in the [ __ ]
laughter like Joey Diaz yeah yeah
totally so it's like I think there's
also that but also you don't stand up in
England yeah they heckling is a very big
part and up culture yeah this like they
yell you [ __ ] you that wasn't funny like
after every joke there barehanded yes
yeah but uh yeah I don't know that is
interesting I think in general Americans
from what I've noticed in terms of like
casting actors they don't want to hear
English people it's like why does that
person think becoming global though I
had a giant Swedish guy walkers me just
blond guy just smiling and I was like
well I don't know he's gonna he's loping
towards me he was giant he looked like a
giant crane yeah I was like that's a
huge man with his knees were up to my
face [ __ ] you're on my screensaver
fighting in Sweden Sweden a via that a
big part of their just gusta fins like
their biggest fighter but he retired
after it's over them it's not huge okay
but are there an athletic people oh yes
they more more coal penalty per capita
in the Olympics oh really
Sweden was it crushes me especially the
Winter Olympics oh wow 7 million people
8 million people have you toured over in
um I've known Navy a good I've been to
the fjords and you don't I did and it
was um it was a trip how long ago did
you go I want to do that by going there
for years four years ago it was Norway
Sweden Iceland Belgium a couple I want
to do that Amsterdam it was fun there
was something kind of crazy the culture
is very different towards women this is
not me being an annoying feminist but
they like in Norway they don't have
strip clubs in Norway well that's
ridiculous
zero oh yeah what's that very
egalitarian yes but not only it's not
like the government is making it happen
like one opened in Bergen and I saw it
and they people vandalized it and
boycotted first of all nudity in
Scandinavia is you when you go to the
fjords and you drop on the water father
so I'm not abou everybody's naked yeah
so those kind of issues they everybody's
naked
they don't repress everything and need
to let it out you're all naked let's say
the happiest
but I call them that yeah but I called
them or I didn't call I called the
Norway a journalist had called me for
some interview and I was like joking I
was like looked up like some whatever
statistics about Norway to try to have a
conversation point with this journalist
knows like hey I heard you guys have
strip clubs with the folk like clowning
on them about it like [ __ ] [ __ ]
like whatever and I was like why don't
you strip clubs like what law is making
this happen and he goes oh no it's just
that over here we we like respect women
y'all know but I found that like even
when I was doing shows there was I think
of us in Belgium when I felt like I was
bombing it was material that like works
everywhere and I was doing a bit about
something about like fighting with a guy
and like how a guy like hangs up on you
and you have to call back or if you
can't relate to it no literally everyone
I was a problem three people just like
we don't do things yeah yeah they're
very egalitarian houses the people that
were there there was like a group of
women like eight women in the front row
and I was like thank you ladies thank
all we're saying all aren't we and
they're like totally yeah that's my in
Europe I always say it's like if you in
Italy Spain France so when you don't
it's not like dating like you don't
really don't go hey I want to take you
out what happens is you hang out as a
group yeah that's girls and guys hang
out for a long time and then it just
kind of had to go there friends which is
a nursing yes use 100 percent friends
it's so so this idea of like film or sex
they do the United States is very
adversarial you're a chick I'm a guy I
gotta get you get up like I need some
stats is that right you don't you have
the stats somewhere in your relationship
it's a very different I know but it was
interesting that that there were these
single women in the front row and I was
like thing go ladies whatever Beyonce
joke and they were like oh no we
actually have husbands and I'm like okay
well where are they and they were like
this woman was like other at home
watching the kids y'all and I was like
yeah right
sounds right you know no our husbands
like take care of children like we have
weird I don't care you know so was like
it a lot of module about disrespecting
women might not kill as hard as it kills
you yeah it was wild
but I did find myself in Sweden like
talking and Nancy ating to make sure
everyone understood me and the mean
great everyone spoke better English than
me yeah
I would know accent usually because it's
phonetically except it's phonetically so
similar perfection you have a little bit
about you know yeah I did find that I
dated an English guy for a minute and I
did find it weird how many girlfriends
he had that we're not girlfriend yeah I
mean oh you mean like friends who
everyone yes there's like the dynamic
he's talking about there's lots of just
friends yeah friend group I feel when
I'm getting old before I we used to
always make that joke if I have a friend
I'm definitely want to [ __ ] him as I get
older especially if they're smarter I
know how I joke
yeah is that as they're smart especially
they're smarter I have more friends who
are women yeah that I don't want to
sleep yes get over in your did you get
older you're a fake and you're when
you're 21 you're 21 you're on guns I
don't I don't want it oh wait so who are
your girlfriends
there's lots of women that I'm friends
with it are smart that I don't want to
[ __ ] come on name's Jennifer there's
bore by just wanna [ __ ] know their
names though I'm not gonna air out a
list of I love it you guys just kind of
don't have agendas then you're like the
guest has to run the show we just do a
conversation get our ratings and
everything great you're doing all the
work for us beauty is this people have
more sex in Nigeria and Mexico more
exciting what's exciting me though wait
often my people have more exciting sex
in Mexico yeah cuz of cartels I feel
like people heroin or twice I feel like
you make a correlation the healthiest
people have the best sex like that's why
maybe in markets I think so
like if you're feeling good about
yourself in your health and you have
energy you're gonna [ __ ] right you know
you said this so aggressive
me it's towels really tiny is good
weather this exhaust yeah like when does
anyone have something with a kid but
like Brazil Brazil my yeah me yeah this
is yeah I mean Miami they have nothing
dude last news in Miami people were
doing blow at like 7:00 p.m. before
shows oh yeah you guys are still just do
these no Scarface the priests number one
Brazil there's a rush a 210 years ago
just just keep in mind right we'll try
now whatever sense I don't believe China
Russia that's because the men are
forcing the women but yeah yeah oh God
fact-check McGee over here again you
just made a generalization about a
billion people pretty true over in
Russia yeah
oh I think you're saying China no rush
oh good looking people in Russia I know
the gorgeous yeah man and women come
here everyday comedy rushing with me for
my men they're a good-looking group of
people the Russian Russian men and women
yeah good-looking people have you seen
that Vladimir Putin doing dude lighting
judo black belt where everybody is
pretending yeah he's a black belt in
judo hey he's a black belt where around
some Samba to today have you seen you've
seen the video of everyone like
pretending did you know you do you know
he's good in Jerry drills you for you
you you you could tell me that video
that he's good do we do you in judo when
you're doing drills you let the guy flip
you there's a way to fall on stuff like
that so that's him okay so he's good
he's just doing it to a demonstration
just they're going through drills like
me that the guys in it are like yeah
well have you have you seen Steven
Seagal stuff though yeah he's with them
you've never seen and he's just trilling
that's her doing calisthenics what is
this what are the knees to the collapses
yeah
in the park are you tennis or pre like
Taekwondo in the park yeah stretch
judoka
[ __ ] dork
I like the way you're talking about mr.
Putin no it's all right that it's he
married I don't anything about him I
don't know nothing I don't know decide
you don't dangerous man no see his kids
or his wife ever I've never seen that oh
hi for good reason hmm they got some
wrestlers in Russia yeah yeah I've never
been I was there when it was communist
really 1985 was it fun it was the most
oppressive greatest place in the world
but I was with my friend spoke fluent
Russian and I have all these kids jeans
Nikes cars they didn't have anything
like wait this is blowing my mind yes
when was that I was in high school
senior in high school so there's no
bunnies and hooked up with girls had my
first threesome there my first threesome
really with two 21 year olds I'm
Christina and my buddy chickened out
couldn't get a hard-on a little [ __ ]
baby and I'm the guy you know [ __ ] you
baby so it's just me you know the fact
that you were there is why he couldn't
get her as older than me christina was
trying to get him gone he couldn't do it
he was like dude yeah insane bet so why
did say their bed next thing hey so
Svetlana they were so hot so Christina
so you get he freaks out goes out so
Christina comes over to my bed the first
time I've been with two girls I'm like
holy bug so I go to town and then my
friend comes and I'm like Brian Jim but
that's in the cosmos hotel the biggest
hotel in the world my friend comes I was
you're Brian your mother's downstairs it
was a two-story suite I go what just
[ __ ] your mother's downstairs too I'm 18
I pull my jeans on I go I look down and
my mom and the railing my mom goes and I
go how did you find me she goes I'm a
witch and I know where you are and I
checked that my sister was sick I wasn't
in the room
she walked biggest hotel in the world
biggest found me because the door was
cracked mother can smelled you [ __ ] it
she didn't hear me [ __ ] Svetlana
comes out completely naked looks down
and my mother goes well see while you're
here I we come back down we drank caviar
we ate caviar enjoy boys drank vodka
with your
with my mom until for me where did your
mom come from I was on a family trip
with my mother did you mom was in Russia
also CIA oh I was like Jesus your mother
died yeah well I grew up overseas
remember I didn't move this guy I tell
us 42 I know nothing about you mom I
know I moved to the state's when I was
14
okay I'd never lived in the cut in this
country until I was 14 oh I lived in
seven different countries I know that
you want to do another couple hour
specials on birds but you should talk
about that
that is so [ __ ] I know you're doing
ostriches next job with all like the
pigeon head movements but goddamn it
matters more to me than just that when
amazing yeah yeah I didn't know I was I
was in China when it was communist when
everybody was on bicycles and in nothing
but blue uniforms Wow let me ask you do
they get this in China because isn't it
regular or they don't so I was very shot
moving in Beijing where the idea had at
five yeah I shot a movie in Beijing
you're less than a year ago well your
viewers want to want to know what that
you can't just say that well now I say a
lot well it was an amazing idea well the
fans know what I'm talking about problem
oh they don't know why I don't know but
my idea was to have it's in it's stupid
at the time a third makes sense but like
because podcasting so big in the States
but like troops listen it all over oh
yeah so but also in like China port you
know so Chinese Portuguese Spanish you
could have two guys translating for me
and bryant's of the you'd be the first
podcast that was globally listened to so
someone has to memorize everything you
say and say in another yeah but they'd
have to have our personalities and stuff
yeah it'd be a nightmare but that was my
idea like six years ago and Fox it will
get right on to do a global search for
people with your personality yeah
oh it'd be a beef that'd be kind of
funny gotta watch auditions I know
do you have anyone that looks like you
have you had any people come out of the
woodwork that's like a doppelganger just
yeah I'm hearty I have some
maybe the hearty party part but like you
know that we all have someone somewhere
in the world that looks exactly like I
guess and when you're famous the chances
of you meeting that person go up I have
someone in Portland that looks exactly
like me do you have a picture so I wire
beneath lights she's gonna plot his body
look like David Blaine
certainly does David playing with Down's
see can you see the moon
see we were googling statistics that I
was trying to catch up
I'm really trying that to make this
podcasting let's see let's see your
topple can you turn a launch on pocket
sit relax is that her that's her wow she
just look no I uh oh my god no I'll go
down you go down
now tell me what she but we also like
move alike and like talk alike that's
her right that's her that's her daughter
hold on keep going down keep going down
that's her reading my book that's like
there's lots of stuff we both got glass
is all like bottom let like see in the
striped shirt like just at that angle
that's us in the same photo oh my god
it's kind of wild that as well that's
[ __ ] like someone that's fair oh not
Oman to that still want attention info
about a sick no I'm saying as far as do
you think she had an spot-on just
friend never told her the other one
chess that's pretty uncanny actually
it's pretty wild look at this one that
one now this one Hugh I would swear
these kind of I would swear that you
come on that looks like you know that
one look certain pictures yeah certain
like that's just gang rosy like I mean
it'd be any closer it'd be a crier
that's yeah any closer would be a lahar
me you guys thought about fooling your
resources and just that won't some guy
no I did I was like I want a t-shirt
like her on that thing above that I
don't know anything about Pilates
equipment her Pilates as hard as [ __ ]
really
I heard it's really hard okay I don't
know why we're watching of course we
thought that that might be a good video
for some reason have you seen that
documentary triplets yeah yo that's a
mind [ __ ] I gotta watch look at that I
mean with the baby what her mouth is
open she's smiling you guys like said
things like corners of our mouths and
your eyebrows in skin hair come on that
looks a lot weird the eyebrows maybe
that's a doppelganger yeah it's as
opposed to as tiny nostrils are I
wouldn't I would think that's you in a
picture right do you think yes so you
haven't found anybody if you guys have
doppelgangers that look like these too
high a couple of guys but I know some
jujitsu guy they always tell me the
worst is when someone comes up to use it
everyone tells me we look alike and
you're like my god she looks like [ __ ]
yeah so when she yelled it out someone's
like my friend look is like you I was
like here we go this is about to hurt my
feelings
look at that video with the circle thing
know it sounds funny that moves this is
the first one I saw that kind of blew my
mind yeah she looks a lot like it it's
not I mean come on it doesn't get much
closer I agree
but I'm surprised people would I'm
you're the judge I haven't said anything
judgey I don't think you guys look that
much alike really really no I do come on
same shape face like your sister has a
different dad who's Hispanic no you're
crazy
it's amazing how you can't see that well
no I see how you guys see it I don't
your promises I don't think it's like a
homerun do you guys I think she loved a
many glasses now number but the I can't
believe no one's come out with
work and they have there's some guy
place for Liverpool's name for his name
he's a midfielder for Liverpool everyone
tags this he's a month you start talking
you look like the murderer I remember we
used to go to luncheon people thought
your Hernandez yes yeah a shaved head
there was the money it's a murder
there's this moment where anytime we
would go like hang out someone would be
look at you and you believe that person
because that a shaved head when he was
on drugs when he was hot is when he's
papa
when he's on trial when he murdered like
seven people yeah that's right yeah yeah
that's right not bad
not a bad he died yeah commit suicide
that's awful what's he not gonna get out
no no I don't have people I'm just gonna
text you the rest I'm sorry sorry I'm
not gonna let this patch as he doesn't I
let my cleaning people and like you
could just pay you know like take a
month off and okay I'm not I'm mentally
need a break like you can say that so I
can go do I might go on my vacation yeah
where do I go on vacation yeah I I want
to see this I went the last great
vacation I went on was the Maldives and
then it's a great it was amazing you
want with you it's amazing yes
very worth going really it's also
sinking so it's not gonna be around much
longer it's helpful there is everything
far right not that far I don't people
like you [ __ ] drive runnin that's
everyone tagged me in him together it's
the square hairline and the general I
feel like me and him look as much as you
and that random girl Phantogram know
well you're not the same ethnicity as
this person I look just like Saddam it
might be I wish I don't know what it is
have you figured out have you done in
23andme have you figured all their watch
I never sent in the stuff I don't want
to find out every can Tamra can I know a
lot of people who were finding out their
parents aren't their parents I see why
people think you look alike
I mean um sort of but I'm recalling I'm
like he's a stud yeah yeah
okay that's better not know
that hair looks that's a helmet de pili
yeah that looks that's like Steve
Rannazzisi okay that's like I haven't
seen him in a long time where has he
been
I just saw him he's on the road I where
was I oh I was in Indianapolis and he's
something happened as flight so he was
like doing they have like a small room
there he's gonna show in there then we
got dinner afterwards he's a good Hank
yes ya know greatest story that's Tommy
impression of anybody but uh wait what
were you just gonna ask me vacation
leaves and then I went to a wedding in
Ravello Italy unbelievable bro fella
where's Robert it's near post sodanope
amo nope what's the other one no FanDuel
rivality Amalfi Coast and you have to
drive up really high I actually got
altitude sickness oh my god
but it is so unbelievably that's right
ravello there's a place called Hotel
Caruso I want which is I think the best
hotel in the world Sebastian went there
recently Instagram and I this is where
I'm a [ __ ] Nam movie the guy what
Kevin Spacey played gore Vidal this
record all used to go all the time yeah
there was a wedding here I think that's
the village in brown where it needs to
get there kind of you fly into Rome it's
like a two-hour drive I'm out it's
pretty [ __ ] worth it though but then
you can go to Rome and then you go to
Florence and then you can go here
there's a place called monastere oh [ __ ]
Santa Rosa monastere oh that is very
beautiful hotel I've ever seen it's an
old monastery that's on a cliff you
might interested yes huh you stay there
stay there
really it's unbelievable how expensive
it is bring that up and it's gotta be
it's gotta be [ __ ] that's gotta be
stupid expensive yes how much how much I
think it was like 2,000 a night
Jesus Christ no dents is that what I'm
supposed to say yeah no dents fur isn't
that beautiful it is worth but this is
like a honeymoon place you don't just
you know you go for like a real thing
and then look up Hotel Caruso so
gorgeous gotta get those points HN go to
Expedia canoe well yeah why it's good
let's see how much kayak org
we're gonna go on vacation uh-uh I've
been to Bora Bora
oh how was that amazing I do I've been
to totora which is Brando's island I
hear that's great that's the crazy
that's what I was gonna ask you but we
need to go to that you are Ramle my
friend oh my dad this is the hotel crew
so look how gorgeous and then is there a
way of the view to look at the view
that's something yeah it's wild she's
wild
come on and I am NOT a big fussy
vacation person like I don't know on me
some places are amazing but actually
hate hear about beautification the other
I know you're being such a bummer right
now hey man yeah you're being monkeys I
don't care but let me ask you do you
know I don't you and Chris don't
vacation not really I don't know life
you're so good like I don't need them
xscape like like in three days I'm good
and I'm I love what I do I agree but I
think for me I get such bad like burnout
and it's so hard for me to disconnect
that sometimes have to go to like the
opposite time zone so that I'm not gonna
email it yeah but I think so exhausting
isn't someone goes on vacation then they
ask you how's your trip and then people
go over their trip I don't give a [ __ ]
about your but I do think there's like
it like pictures like in Google I don't
wanna see your pictures there's like
when they go the zoo yeah well I am very
well most people you have to understand
are boring and most people need photos
also um on the pictures it's that's the
what that's interesting to most people
that's true you're just too highly
stimulated and you are round
statistically the most entertaining
people on the planet all the time for
most people that's their big closer you
know a hard percent I was just talking
about this about like weddings and
people like why are you like planning a
wedding I'm like because I'm the center
of attention too much as it is actually
don't want to do that oh man well that's
like when I when I work at Lehman
Brothers wait what without for almost
two years as a banker yeah you've been
doing jokes about vultures for 15 years
why don't you talk about that Lehman
Brothers did you see my last special
comp candidates no I said okay they can
you talked about it let's take a look at
it okay well I posted about it but but
but yeah I remember I had a two-week
vacation and it was when you're waking
up every day and like grind when it's
still dark
give me the berry from hobo wild and
you're on
in a suit you know and you go and do
that weird [ __ ] in the cubicle yeah and
you finally can get away for two weeks
oh my god I never liked signing break
when your school you don't care where
you're going you don't care you're going
either you don't care for tests yeah
yeah I thought it explains Fort
Lauderdale's your guys education yeah I
became an actor I would go to bubbies
and see actors and I was like I want to
be an actor so I don't have to do this
yeah well that's wild I was desperate
and that's the other thing about you
know anything we don't think about this
a lot when people go to comedy shows
it's like they want they jibba deal oh
my god look at a [ __ ] notepad what
else is happening for you [ __ ] Numa
Tara there's like this is my break
podcasters normal brain yo be it's back
to school you know what that means
Oh traffic but also a sale from on it
50% off really fit your cent off so for
you
Pappas out there or you momma's maybe
you're stressed out with your kid going
back to school get yourself a little
something little something solve it
yourself a little our body I realized
maybe maybe total human new mood what's
up some frickin gut health yeah got
health baby want some shroom tag crude
oil maybe some gut health says crows bad
for you nobody what about some earth
girl nutrients either way select the
items are 50% off maybe need some
nutrition maybe need some fitness scare
apparel whenever you want 50% off back
to school stale starts right now you
keto Papa's out there they got your fat
butter the a warrior Hoss they got it
all man go to audit dot-com slash
fighter right now the back of school
sale starts now
50% off gives you some on at comm slash
fighter sorry
hashtag great dad mmm I think you're a
[ __ ] great dad
I try to be I was boogie boarding with
my kids yesterday was so much fun really
Santa Monica hit in the Whitewater like
I bet you're such a good dad because I
bet you let your kids fail so they can
learn yeah right you don't protect well
I also do little things like I build I
like to build little mythology
for them I'll have somebody call like no
no I have people I'll do stuff wait
there I thought were still talking
vacations ever tell what we do with our
kids let's do it all right yeah I'm
ready
yep I had my friend friend call me and
offer me $200,000 for a gig and I just
said offer me $200,000 for this gig in
Australia and my daughter my summer in
the car and I go and I had him on
speaker and he goes it's $200,000 and I
go can't do it man and they go why I
can't be away from my kids for more than
four days or I freak out not know is a
fake off oh okay fake off and my
daughter goes to do it dad do it do it I
go no I can't I can't be away from you
guys more than four days tell your
master yeah should I create this thing
don't be stupid we don't care you can
Skype with us that do it well FaceTime
do it she was freaking out that I was
leaving money on the making bad
financial decisions that's a super good
reason for the yes yes and then I'll do
so like this I'll be like look man the
thing about Finn is that he just he
never gives up he specially-trained
names trying you know so I build this
thing like I'll cast them as somebody
who keeps trying even when they're
failing and stuff like that but I think
that parents these days from what I know
these days I said it are like I mean the
helicopter parents but it's like no
one's trust their parents know their
kids fail ports yeah I don't know I
watch my kid get bullied there's a
hardest thing I've ever had to deal with
ah it bummed me out
I don't get bummed out or daddy because
I couldn't do I will
I know I will fight again I had to let
him I had to let him figure it out I had
to let the coach fix it out I had to let
my son deal with it and I watched it and
it was not physically could hit him
stomach I would a son didn't understand
let me be able to handle it and then
they were mean they had an okay kid yeah
I know but you're mad at the other
parents they're eight but it was a grab
him by the face in like I know it was a
it was a baseball camp and you know
that's you know I had to let it kind of
it heard me do you talk to the parents
is there any point no cuz they weren't
there it was the coup the cut explains
their coach interfered the coach came
involved
but I didn't sleep well for two kids
need to be not bullied chronic what you
draw but there is a place for adversity
yes yes that's what sports are for
that's what all this stuff is for yeah
that's what life is gonna kick you in
the nuts sooner or later you do like
allowance no just curious do they give
they earned points to leave here I had
yes money was our primary way of showing
love in my household but ya know we
definitely had allowances because back
then that was the only way to punish a
kid now it's through the phone I guess
you can say like I'm gonna take Lola we
can take the iPad what the iPad you take
was there still allowances I'm sure I
did my family it was like I got whatever
20 bucks a week if I knocked it out I
didn't get it yeah the biggest thing is
phone but especially iPad take away frog
if you tell you I pay you like freak out
but when do you do cell phones how do
you know my daughter now at 11 has a
cell phone
four inches high so easy yeah but for
emergencies like she's going she allowed
a little screen it's tough if the rest
of the kids happen if the wrestling
that's well there's also the big thing
I'm finding is that people will take
photos of your kid and then put it on
Facebook they're like from how do you
well with the very dangerous tweens
especially girls are very socially
aggressive yeah so they they Internet
well he used to be you get bullied at
school and it was left there and you got
you you got deal with it or whatever but
now it's like I heard it a school in
Brentwood eridan California like near
here that some girls photoshopped a
girl's head on a naked body and show the
Internet forever
well yeah I think that's why depressions
up suicides of anxiety social I imagine
like in our day if you would just go on
Monday and found out that two people
hung out over the weekend like you were
so bummed but like you know at least
you'd find out after the fact and now
you're just like would be watching your
friends hanging out at a party I know
that's why I think instagrams get even
though I just posted me cell brain get a
million followers but I think it's
Ramsey now the well like a few days ago
and I'm 36 but but they did they're
getting rid of followers yeah they're
getting rid of still kind of young is
that gonna happen they're getting rid of
followers yeah yeah because
it's like taking such a toll on the
younger generation but they equivalent
that to being like what do you not say
wait great quick yes but they quit that
but we like to like that's their worth
that's right but I don't think Twitter's
get rid of it or Facebook just Instagram
because people like us who make our
money based on it becomes your actual
worth yes but it shouldn't be true why
would be actual why do you [ __ ] see
how many people I'm gonna refresh hold
on for you but the the fans don't need
to know that yeah but I think that most
people oh you'll know it like like you
like what they're gonna do is you're
gonna be I'll see how many followers you
out and then people like everyone else
isn't going to yeah but your business
contacts will know how many followers
right I mean I don't do endorsements on
my thing yeah but you have to show them
that to get more money oh yeah
they're like being paid to post or
whatever yeah or like posting an ad or
getting an endorsement deal or something
like that is based on your follower
count now it's wild hmm you know like
they're showing that like follower count
doesn't really translate into eyeballs
in television but it does translate into
moving merchandise that made it well to
disconnect that thing yeah it's people a
million follower him on a TV show is not
gonna move the needle no not at night
well close not even like to the point
wow it's because I in the last couple
things that I've done everyone's like
hire this person who's got 50 million
followers and this influencer never
matters nothing and that's incredible
yeah a demo because it's not like if
you're in podcasting and you'll see some
like new podcasters to go on like Jimmy
Fallon and promote it there and they'll
go on this TV show but the podcast
listeners really not there no that gamma
and then I also I think people want and
correct I'm sure your fans will correct
me in the comments but I you and my
English you go that's a rough day the
basically if someone's watching you do
[ __ ] around on Instagram with Chris
like I want to see you do that
I don't have to see you be someone I got
I got a it's Chris have me the funniest
thing I got a post today about oh my god
you do it right now no
but I'm did you and Chris get along at
first yeah
really right right yeah best mmm did I
know cuz i when i was younger though he
was just I remember I hold was he when
he met him cuz one heater something you
when we started because Chris and I
basically started at the same I'll say
you and Chris were friends right off the
bat I knew Chris when he was married
yeah me too
but you were Fred right like right when
you guys came to LA you guys were
friends mother I guess huh no we do each
other kwitny what are you talking I know
but you were senior to me yeah so I was
like oh that's Bryan Callen yeah but we
knew each other but yeah but you guys
but we didn't like do the same no you
were doing clubs I was doing like rooms
yes you and Chris came here at the same
time we're friends right away we were
friends we met at a lot in Long Beach at
some [ __ ] stand-up some horrible
stand-up show with like a bowling alley
and we were sick instant yeah instant
friends I think he's weird he was like I
remember being like thinking he was like
kind of a weirdo you know cuz he I used
this torture him and I I love that
Callie I he'd luck he got the joke yeah
so I used to just you know I'd be like
you died say things like let me borrow
your wife for the weekend I got these
Russian guys in town you can't borrow my
wife dude and he was married before yeah
I mean there's a lot of kind because
there's so many comics and now that in
the beginning we like it's not that we
didn't get along it's just we never were
friends and then now we're so close and
you remember those years where we like
work friends yeah like it's just so wild
you just were all it's a small
fraternity yeah and it's like we all
know what's up it's like it's a small
fraternity yeah like I see comics in
airports that I've never met before
and we're just like instant family and
then we're like this is our first time
meeting so we're all doing the same so
yeah yeah and there's something very
like when when I'm so drogon myself
10,000 takes bill burr may sell 10,000
tickets when we're at the Comedy Store
that of [ __ ] goes out the window we're
all just comics yeah and oh by the way
you're as good as the last joke you
wrote this doesn't get easier for
anybody it's not like I'm a master at
comedy now and I can just get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah but you are you've
always been so [ __ ] funny and such
like ridiculously for a different way
they used to i definitely been jealous
of you before thank you cheesy like you
like because it's not something I don't
think what you do can be taught nope
thank you like I was good but I also
think Bryan
in person is one of the best comics a
lot well if you have to see him in
person Kay so physical it's yeah I agree
I agree there's a limit to what the
camera can really capture and there's a
limit to how much like the confidence
you have is just unmatched well I
appreciate and how you commit to
something so ridiculous for so long I
feel like we use do remember that
placement I think we should have a long
[Music]
I want that to be the closer jealous of
you all that's the greatest [ __ ]
compliment I've ever heard and and and I
want to end it right there your total
applications not going out what what is
your qualms I'm not sure we want to keep
going wait she just annotated a
compliment your friend ladies let's end
it on that we love you Whitney we love
you you're the best right now
and tear me up I will never tear you
apart they will never tear you apart
no you look awesome in Ric advance' your
[ __ ] greatness you're a great homage
how about that can I touch it up we
don't label Netflix original can I touch
it watch it or [ __ ] die well my
favorite comic is the favorite you tell
me getting ready for I thought it was
the [ __ ] you're doing in the common
story I [ __ ] and I've complimented you
on this podcast before I even saw this
like you so yes we love it we love you
and we love you this the finala kid
right if you have listened this far god
bless you if you made it this far